Jane Gaines is professor of film here at
Columbia University previously she
founded and directed the program and
filmed the video digital studies at Duke
University and she's won national awards
for two books and she has also published
articles on intellectual property and
early film piracy as well as documentary
film and video and currently she is
completing fictional of fiction astir
ease women film pioneers a project for
which she received an academy of motion
picture arts and sciences scholar award
okay thank you Beth it's very very
exciting to be here at the first
conference on the Makino collection and
to be part of the community of
international scholars who will change
the course of what we have called cinema
history I'm introducing the three
panelists together to save time because
they're so much material and perhaps
this is just an indication of things to
come because every time someone finds
something that could connect to the
Makino the project just balloons so
first in order of the paper presentation
professor why Hong Bao I want to
introduce is my colleague and assistant
professor here in Chinese film and media
in the department of east asian
languages and cultures and to anticipate
her forthcoming book manuscript dances
of fire aesthetic effect in the
intermediate of Chinese cinema 1884
which is very early for cinema
beginnings add to 1945 and anticipate
secondly her project in progress
underway imagined as she finishes the
first the shadowy theater of Chinese
cinema and and these two projects should
be working on in Germany next semester
so after a professor boughs talk which
she has here on the screen put up
constellar travelers introduction of
montage in China we will have the second
presentation by Professor Ted Hughes
who's associate professor of modern
Korean literature here in East
asian languages and literatures his
first book on literature and film in
Cold War South Korea is called freedoms
frontier and he also has a second book
cultural history of the Korean War
titled the remembered war now the third
panelist Oh professor Hughes will speak
on the archive phobia which for him and
blocks out the problem of Korean cinema
and its particular colonial pass in the
relation to Japan the third presentation
by dr. rico y cagada is a presentation
which will be in Japanese but hickory
hadi has passed out the English
translation so those of you fluent in
Japanese will be able to enjoy her paper
on Japanese female director sac Anita
Zuko who was aligned with the Manchurian
film Association and it's about the
archival materials that she used in
researching japanese colonial films now
a little more about dr. rico y cagada
who is interesting for us because she
has a PhD in literature from the
calamaro women's university which he
received in 2006 and since she has been
adjunct lecturer on the faculty of
comparative culture at otsuma women's
university this is of course for Western
scholars very fascinating that there
should be women's university so we'll
need to hear more about that I I
understand this is a perfect project and
perfect placement for her that her
dissertation which was a study of sac
Anita Zuko in particular has been not
only published in Japan but received a
significant prestigious prize the now
oyama prize from the Institute for
Women's Studies in Tokyo so that third
paper will be in paper handout form but
also you will
in japanese so we have just a short
response and then I plan to lead
discussion time so the panelists at that
point we'll come back up and I hope he
cut he can join us to translate
questions for professor ekata 08 cagada
am i doing all eight equip grata let go
he got okay so two to return to Ted
Hughes paper I wanted to comment on his
title arkive phobia which he uses to
preface his discussion of Korean cinema
and it's problematic relation to its
colonial master Japan and I'm guessing
that his archive phobia is a rather sly
reference to Jacques Derrida as archive
fever which we all know to be a very
strange english translation of the
french meld archive which could have
been translated to preserve the
connotations of disease or malady so i
would begin by asking what could
possibly be so Mel Duras about the
Makino memorial collection that attracts
us or is it that we as scholars I so
feverishly driven in our return to such
a monumental set of holdings the largest
of its kind in the world and this I get
this from I want to take a chance so I
have a little more time to thank the
organizers Paul ander Jim Chang he could
a naughty and Beth cat Slav who have
described the Makino collection to me
exhibited it to my students but I have
yet to crack its code so i would mark
here from the outset that the archive is
especially intriguing to scholars who do
not have the japanese language key to it
and thus for whom it comes to stand for
the impenetrability of the historical
past itself and to think that it's here
in the cv starr library just across from
the building where I work so both um
dr. Egan gotta do I'm going to call Rico
and professor Hughes hint that the
collection contains buried relics of the
Japanese colonial era as it may help us
keep alive the hope that historical
archives can be made to give up some of
the secrets of the cultures that they
guard Ted refers to more than one
missing moment in contemporary Korean
history with particular concern about
the 1910 245 colonial era of jacking the
Me's occupation of Korea but back to
derrida who in thinking about finding
nothing seems to comment as well on the
portions of historical time missing from
official accounts when he says although
we find nothing in a place an absence is
not nothing but is rather the space left
by what is gone and I think about this
when I think that even and especially
when thought to be lost there's a way in
which the not there can become all the
more there for us especially as scholars
looking for it in excavating saucony
Tezuka's brides of the continent or as
the translation you have handed out says
frontier a 1943 propaganda film for us
Rico shows us how much was formerly not
nothing an entire war effort based on
the import of Japanese brides to his
part of the effort to colonize Manchuria
an enormous effort that just vanished we
should think a lot as well the
unflinching analysis of what it meant
for a female director to imagine
actually imagine this utopian ism and
the images give us this this utopian
domestic life and to think of it as also
aiding the Japanese and peer
project the very same time serving as a
model of historical research in which
she says effectively port makes us think
that we should never assume anything we
should never assume that there were no
women I never assume uncontradicted
consciousness in historical subjects I
think I get this from reading her
commentary because of the double pneus
the sort of double consciousness of the
early propaganda filmmaker and when I
find incredibly useful is just this
contradictory notion of the Imperial
feminist we never dared call Leni
Riefenstahl on Imperial feminist that
was a taboo and you have nailed it this
is a very useful concept I also in
following professor boughs paper realize
that she urges us to never assume that
there was no connection between
historical subjects as she demonstrates
showing us that the Chinese left wing
movement was linked closely inexorably
to the Japanese proletarian film
movement in the 1930s with all of this
evidence no one could ever deny it again
through these three papers there is also
a fraud question of national cinema a
thread that many of us follow when we
try to do comparative world cinema so
the cases of the Korean Japanese and
Chinese national cinemas buried in the
mecca no collection urges to work
through that collection in an attempt to
try to define it yet again but to my
mind the best definition so far has been
offered by Chinese scholar Chris Perry
who has written an answer to this
question quite simply national cinema is
this cinema made by the nation whatever
that is that's the end of the quote so
we cannot know what is National Center
until we know what it is that the
relatively new political entity the
nation was then again doesn't the claim
to a national cinema especially in cases
like India Iran and now we see from
Ted's paper this emerging moment this
possibility of a rebirth of a Korean
cinema confused with a communist cinema
or anti come in the cinema so all of
these moments seem to correspond to
political upheaval but actually cinema
history makes the entire question of the
nation defined by its culture more not
less difficult something we learn from
what Ted Hughes tells us about how
Korean culture was Japanese popular
culture at the colonial moment and
here's where cinema historians know
something that other scholars of 20th
century culture may have missed and that
is that to the degree that foreign
cinemas became popular motion pictures
in the country that imported them is the
degree to which they became part of the
national culture of the nation that
adopted them and it's impossible to
extricate that borrowed culture
sometimes an enforced culture as it
became popular this is why for example
the for instance Amsterdam Film Archive
preserves and restores so many examples
of national cinema other than its own
because the Dutch with a relatively
small national film industry embraced
German American French cinema and that
is Dutch popular cinema heritage for all
intents and purposes so they are not
about to let that go elsewhere that is
preserved in the Netherlands so from
these papers we see something of the
world traffic in film prints we see this
as during the cinema century a flow that
was quite continual how it is that
motion pictures ended up however and
fiat archives located the
their end of the world from the nation
in which they were originally produced
is one of the questions that is
absolutely obsessing cinema scholars at
this point because as the Federation of
International Film Archives become their
Holies become available and the
treasures from the VF archives database
which we have here at Columbia gets used
by young scholars we discover that in
the cinema century prints were
constantly in circulation both dead end
Rico referred to the recent release of
the late colonial Korean imperialist
vation films called passed on earth as a
DVD series the DVD titles of course our
digital versions of 35 millimeter film
prints that would have to been restored
either by archives within which they
were originally deposited or which they
have recently been or to which they have
recently been shifted and as we call it
repatriated that the Beijing Film
Archive would hold so many Japanese men
a titles and that they could be found as
well in Gus poem poem in Moscow the
library of congress in washington DC the
Imperial War Museum and London comes
then is no surprise to motion picture
historians so to think the mackie no
collection is a vital companion to the
PF motion picture print holdings is to
see the Makino collection is a source of
underling at Ted's term here from
amateur collecting this is another kind
of shadow history a shadow history where
the prince and the actually printed
material sort of follow one another but
these most important for us these prints
in circulation
and this material that explains the
exhibition history tell us what we call
in cinema history the life stories of
motion picture prints themselves how did
they arrive there how did this
collection from Manchuria get to Moscow
it's amazing so professor bow however
reminds us thinking about the public
discourse around the moment of the
release of motion pictures that film
Theory traveled to that a single trans
lingual issed like lewd now could leave
over cultural barriers and stimulate a
parallel what she calls traffic in
international film theory but the
question for her I'd have is yes there
is motion pictures circulation and
submission traffic the movement of
pieces of prints fragments then and now
and whole prints when they were before
they had begun to decompose but do we
want to parallel film theories discourse
around or we also think that was going
in opposite directions professor Hughes
I want to end by referring to a portion
of his paper that sort of didn't make it
into the talk but in the printed version
he ends by addressing his hopes that the
machina will serve as the site were
other pre-1945 korean as well as other
japanese pasts plural can emerge and i
think of the plural pasts in relation to
debates a number of us have had quite
recently about what we call our
histories of film theories international
translation project justice we have
gravitated or imagined ourselves
rabbeting toward the plural histories
and the plural theories we would want to
think of the Makino is containing the
seeds of writings not about the history
of Japanese cinema but about historical
past
plural about the many national cultural
film legacies that pass through Japan on
their way somewhere else and that would
make this secret of the mech e note the
very infinitude of the possible pass for
which it keeps the keys so let's open
this up to discussion will have the
three panelists well I'll ask my hard
question to Professor bow I always like
to ask a question a difficult question
that fascinates me and to which I don't
have an answer so I'm going to ask my
hundred you to think about since you
know so much having done work in the
Taiwanese archives and i love the 9.5
discovery in the taiwanese archives so
you find this amateur work by the
translator in taiwan but you've also
done research in beijing and thinking of
that research and how amazed you are
when you find 35 millimeter prints here
and there are nine point five millimeter
how do you think this when you start a
project which is a film traveling film
theory project you do ever try to think
the two together and think the metaphor
of traveling is working or not working
in terms of discourses and intellectual
legacies the wonderful work you're doing
on stores shops magazines do that maybe
the simple question is do they travel in
the same or different circles the prince
and the discourses in the journals